I went into the book thinking that being
a man in reality is about being loyal
and being present and I'm being honest
and and I found that's bull be a man is
a gift it's about getting me to the face
I ran into joy hi i'm tim cavanaugh the
reason TV we're here with Joel Stein a
columnist writer and author most
recently of man made a stupid quest for
masculinity Joel thanks for joining us
thank you for having me in my house it's
great to catch up with you and tell us a
little bit about the book
you look great first of all that you
look great is not la we all look great
the book happened because I found out we
were having a son and I freaked out
because as you know I am not equipped to
raise a male so I went out I tried to
learn as quickly as I could
how to be a man which I started out
slowly I went to become a Boy Scout so
I'd never done that so I went camping
with the Boy Scouts and earned my first
badge and then I ratcheted it up till
eventually I did three days of boot camp
in the army and I fought Randy Couture
for around this UFC fighter now you said
it's because he had a son if you had a
daughter what would be the difference I
would have been relieved I would have
felt like I could raise a daughter all
my friends when I was a kid were girls I
like musicals I had a glass animal
collection I had an easy-bake oven you
know I was prepared to go through
girlhood again but I wasn't I wasn't
prepared to like throw a ball and watch
people on TV throw balls and try and
decide if the results of that ball
throwing was positive or negative like
or fight like my kid might fight or want
a camp so I just wasn't ready for that I
have three girls and I notice when we
are playing they do the dolls and all
this kind of stuff easy right in
situations where they're with their
cousins or neighbors or something like
that and the boys are all you know doing
soccer or whatever I get the real urge
to tell the boys like don't you realize
Barbie has all these cool accessories
and stuff like it's it's way cool to
play this it's much easier to play with
girls right
my son is hitting me with sticks
constantly you know and and and I'm torn
because I don't want to dissuade him
from becoming a real man but I also
don't want to get hit by sticks so
there's there's a fine line
what was the manly thing that you hated
doing most I hated hunting the most not
the killing the animal part the being in
the woods for hours sitting quietly
thinking about animals you make 400 K a
year apparently it was a good year last
year and I printed that in the magazine
and now all journalists hate me in fact
all people everywhere except Mitt Romney
hates me yeah I believe in all
journalists hate you that's a good sign
that's that's pretty damn manly though
making hell cash like that is is pretty
alpha
that's depends how you make it right I
don't feel like I think man the day
trading is mailing is you're actually
taking it from another guy you're
beating him on the trade but like
getting it for a book advance doesn't
seem that manly we're entering into a
universe where supposedly in a few years
there will be more female heads of
households than male there's no
breadwinners is it all over for men at
that point or what's then it's been all
over for men since we left the caves I
mean technology is always making life
easier and making us less manly our guys
were manlier than us cuz they had to
like fix stuff around the house and fix
their TVs at least right if you watch
Mad Men Don Draper seems like a man but
when they show his dad during the
Depression coming home from the mine
with his face all dirty and like beating
his son like he's much manlier than Don
right I think that just keeps going back
so yeah we're doing talk a little bit
about what you did actually I was
freaked out about a lot of these things
but I was really scared about doing
three days of boot camp with a troop
they let me sleep with them and train
with them embarrassing thing is about
three hours into boot camp before I done
any physical activity whatsoever it was
hot and apparently I locked my knees I
fainted I've never fainted before never
fainted after but I fainted into the
arms of a soldier which was pretty
humiliating when you swooned I mean was
it a comforting feeling when he caught
you I don't know I don't remember it I
mean I you've never fainted obviously
you're a man you've why would you feel
yeah I never fainted either all I knew
is I was sitting by a tree and I don't
remember anyone telling me to sit by a
tree well sue them awhile apparently I
answered questions incorrectly for a
while yeah I don't I don't know what
happened I just know it became very
light did they put you know toothpaste
in your ear or anything like that when
you were passed it's funny I talked to
Rob Riggle this comedian
Marines and he warned me about being
dehydrated maybe he said make sure you
don't faint because then you get the
Silver Bullet and so I was like what's
the Silver Bullet he's like they stick a
thermometer in your ass put you in a
baby pool of cold water and I was like
of course they do it's like that's what
guys do to guys he's like no you idiot
that's safety I think they're just
trying to bring your body temperature
down I'm like oh it's not a prank like
no no prank weird the army it's no prank
so when I woke up and I was in this room
and they had thrown all this water on me
doesn't he gave me Pedialyte which you
know is for infants which was
humiliating not manly I was instantly
afraid that the Silver Bullet was coming
what should the takeaway be for just
regular regular Joe's like myself who
are neither too manly nor too unmanly I
went into the book thinking that my
conclusion was gonna say you know all
this was interesting but in reality
being a man isn't about you know
learning how to fix pipes you know or
fighting Randy Couture being a man and
reality is about being loyal and being
present and I'm being honest and and I
thought that's [ __ ] being a man is
it's about getting kneed in the face by
Randy Couture like each of these things
I did actually made me manlier and it
gave me kind of more of a code to live
by and it made me more confident and
more more capable and I think you only
become a man by doing things not just by
deciding to be a man or by by being a
better person the book has been optioned
for a movie it's not out yet and it's
already been optioned does that prove
that there's a demand for manliness out
there or is it just that the Jews
control Hollywood it's really a
combination of the Jews controlling
Hollywood and people who make movies not
bothering to read books yeah wait don't
buy the book just wait for the movie
well thanks very much
Joel Stein thank you for raising TV I'm
tim cavanaugh we don't I get it say
something
today